[Music]
[Applause]
Marcellus Wiley is set to join us the
former All-Pro defensive end and host of
more to it podcast on The Dan Patrick
Podcast network available wherever you
listen to your podcast this week he
tells us why LeBron's not loving the
game the same as he used to why Joe
burrow may cruise to another Super Bowl
appearance
and why everyone says happy New Year
wrong
where you want to start with that how
about how about it we get it wrong by by
not saying Happy New Years
well actually that's how we get it wrong
happy New Years like we're about to just
go from 2022 to 2023 2024 2025 like it's
only one year and it caught me off guard
too my wife was just eye rolling me uh
December 31st I like oh walking up to
everyone happy New Years Happy New Years
she finally just tapped me on the
shoulders like you know you're getting
that wrong and I was like what and she
was like dude are you trying to make New
Year more than one year and once I
looked at it of course I didn't give her
credit in the moment but I had to take a
step back and now I'm just counting
everybody who gets it wrong including
you Dan happy New Year yeah well I I say
happy new year but I I was wondering
when you were correcting people then
maybe I was getting it wrong by saying
Happy New Year not even confident in it
see that's no point no I think we did it
yeah happy New Year all right uh Monday
night you're watching what are you
thinking as that play unfolds when you
have to The Tackle by Hamlin with t
Higgins
so much to unpack here let's take it
live in the moment as I'm sitting on the
couch with my seven-year-old son who
loves football even more than I did as
an active player he's just all into it
we're watching it and in live time
the way that t Higgins turned up field
made me as a Defender say oh like this
was a abrupt change of what you
anticipated that is not placing blame on
him that's just saying oh this you
caught me off guard now when he caught
him off guard with the head helmet
crowned to the neck head area tackle all
of that Force also you're caught off
guard and it landed right on Demar
Hamlin fine he jumps up only thing that
happened to me in that moment was like
whoa that would that would have caught
me that would have hurt me a little bit
whatever he pops up everything's fine
and then you realize everything's not
fine and what a tragic visual to see uh
someone fighting for their life not
fighting in the NFL football since for
the next yard or the extra yard or for a
touchdown fighting to stay alive and
literally I started crying my son
asked me two things in the moment he's
like Dad
is he going to live
and then he follows that up by saying
Dad I'm glad that didn't happen to you
when you played football and that's why
I was crying fighting it back to stay
strong and show face for my family but I
really was emotional because
I've taken thousands of hits I've given
thousands of hits and to ever see that
that can be the reality because I've
never seen that on the football field
I've never experienced the death of any
player that's actually a conversation in
our home my dad my son always asks dad
has anyone ever died playing football
and I always say heat exhaustion
training camp but no one's ever died
playing football and in that moment that
was in jeopardy
what about the idea of continuing to
play that game at any point
did you sense that the NFL was leaving
open that window
absolutely they were and this is going
to sound harsh but they should have had
to come to play leaving that window open
let me tell you why the example I have
is my mother passed away when I was an
active player 2005.
and I remember when she passed away the
first thing I thought is
life will never be the same I thought it
would never stop being preoccupied with
the loss of my mother and then I also
thought going to bed that night that the
sun wouldn't rise I also thought that
the clouds would cover the whole planet
I just thought everything was going to
be different and you know what happened
the next day
this is the moment where I realized you
have to compartmentalize no matter what
you're going through in tragedy
I had to go to the doctor I had to go to
the mortuary I had to go to the florist
I had to start making plans point being
there is someone's job no matter how
they're emotionally affected to still
keep the Train on the tracks They are
preoccupied with something else I fast
forward to my mother's funeral people
are cracking jokes people are laughing
like what you're going to serve when we
get back to the house and everyone's in
a different Lane affected emotionally
but different tasks at hand it felt
harsh for me even to think about that
but I was talking to my wife in the
moment I was like you know they have
something to think about in this moment
are they going to continue next man up
mentality are they really going to stop
this game so it's not to say that they
made the wrong or right decision it
meant that they had a decision to make
yeah and I I just wondered if they knew
that Hamlin was going to be okay
an hour later and the players are still
there still in uniform in their lockers
locker room
I I wonder if they would have tried to
squeeze that in oh absolutely like the
the bottom line interest was to continue
to play that football game the only
thing that of abrupted at was the fact
that
the you didn't know how he was doing in
terms of his condition so when they
started to look and say oh he fell down
oh he he got a concussion whatever First
Steps what you're thinking the normal
response in that moment the NFL is
thinking okay you guys got a few minutes
probably go to the sidelines and we'll
go back but when it became a life and
death situation without closure
the NFL finally had to suspend that game
because they knew that those players
couldn't come back to that field without
closure any other injury we've seen
including concussion including tour who
stands up and then just passes out when
you have some form of closure or
understanding of what's going on you can
proceed but when you don't obviously the
NFL made the right choice finally and
they had a suspended he's Marcellus
Wiley the former All-Pro defensive end
and host of the podcast more to it
available on The Dan Patrick Podcast
Network
you start to look at a couple other
things with uh you mentioned Joe burrow
like what is it about Joe burrow that
you're seeing that shows or proves last
year was not a one-off this is who he
really is yes between the ears with Joe
burrow man he has all the talent in the
world uh but it's more so his Moxie his
mentality you know how they started off
this season oh and two started slow and
Joe burrow is just someone you can hang
your hat on I think this team rallies
around him and more so they believe in
him because he believes that he can
overcome all adversity and that's what
I'm seeing from this team like they're
greater than the sum of his parts and
they're a talented team but they play
even greater than that because of their
belief system it seems like there are 52
guys that believe in Joe burrow and he
believes that he can conquer all and
when you have a leader like that you
start to feel Invincible you start to
feel like okay I could do everything
because I'm in connection osmosis with
the guy who can do it all so but Joe
Burrows scared because you can never
count them out is the opposite going on
in Denver
um yes and no we were warned about
Russell Wilson and no one wanted to
believe it and buy into it fully we
heard from teammate after teammate that
he lacked leadership authenticity we
heard from teammate after teammate that
he's not the guy that we think he is and
I think we took that in terms of
Personality only but some guys were
actually saying oh he's not the baller
you think he is top defense his first
four years top defenses usually great
running game Pete Carroll and I think
now we're starting to realize oh we may
should have given more Credence to some
of those conversations but you know what
they did in Seattle they just cleaned
the locker room of anybody who disagreed
with Russell Wilson cooking and now
we're starting to realize maybe that
wasn't the smartest decision he hits he
lands in Denver you have a first-year
head coach I'm sure he's trying to grind
the same checking all the same boxes but
when you don't have that in you guys who
don't have Success With You are going to
be sitting there doubting guys are going
to be sitting on the outside saying you
got to bring me in if you're Russell
Wilson because your reputation is one
thing it preceded you but it's not going
to help lead me and I think that's where
we are right now in The Crossroads of
Russell Wilson having to Galvanize
having to start this train and this
momentum again instead of carrying and
riding with what he had in Seattle I
mentioned this a couple of weeks ago and
it sounded crazy to say it but I still
firmly believe it that I needed less
Aaron Rodgers
for the Green Bay Packers to be
successful
I needed the running game and I needed
the defense and I needed Aaron Rodgers
to come up with a couple of big plays I
just didn't need him to be the the
epicenter here
and and maybe I'm crazy in saying that
it just feels like they're a better team
when they run the football that defense
has stepped up and then Aaron can now
make a couple of throws with those young
receivers
you're coming from and I get it at
certain times you need all Aaron Rodgers
especially early in the season even in
Failure you know why what a roster full
of guys who especially in the receiving
Corps who are really trying to get their
bones they needed Aaron Rodgers to take
those hits for him need to be the leader
that he is but then what you're talking
about is later in the season those guys
have to be so inspired and encouraged
that they're actually productive that
they actually step up in a leadership
role so you basically got to activate
those guys but you got to be the First
Act if you're Aaron Rodgers and I've
been on teams like that before when
you're like looking around a Junior Seau
Bruce Smith somebody has to break the
glass and then we all can go run through
and get what we want and it's a
situation where Aaron Rodgers think
early in the season he just had to go
out there and show all these guys hey
you can take your lumps we can fall down
we will get back up and you will stay
alive even in defeat now those guys
believe that they have their experience
and they have that leadership you
mentioned on the podcast why LeBron's
not loving the game the same why
yeah LeBron James came out and said that
uh playing basketball without winning is
not in his DNA anymore and on the
surface that sounds amazing that sounds
like a true winner like oh Jordan look
out LeBron only plays when he wants to
win and he is winning then you take a
step back you know like the old adage no
it doesn't matter how smart you are if
you don't stop and think and you stop
and think about that you say wait a
minute are you still in love with the
process well the results will make you
think he is okay are you still in love
with your individual success in putting
up 27-6 the results say you are
but then you start to realize wait a
minute you're saying you don't love what
you're doing unless there's team success
does that matter if you are not having
individual success does that even play
into how you're approaching the game
processing the game and preparing for
the game so I thought that that even
though it was supposed to be a hard step
if I'm a winner or else maybe actually
question a little bit more about LeBron
James and how he's getting to this place
I know he's balling out of control but
sometimes the results can make us think
different than the process I uh and you
know how this game is played uh the
media game and topics that you have on a
show and I was wondering why is it that
Kawhi Leonard doesn't get criticized
Anthony Davis does
uh you know he plays for the lake if
Kawhi played for the Lakers
then he he would probably get criticized
I think the reason why he doesn't get
criticized for not playing is he plays
for the Clippers I mean is it that
simple if Anthony Davis played for the
Clippers he would not receive anywhere
near this attention and they're a better
team than the Lakers
well Anthony Davis didn't receive his
attention in New Orleans either and I
get what you're saying to the point
um as I look at my clippers chair over
there I'ma defend my team in a weird way
um have you ever noticed this dynamic
the team that loses in the Super Bowl
feels worse than the team that didn't
even make the playoffs I've seen that a
thousand times I felt that I've never
been in the Super Bowl and I've been on
teams that didn't make the playoffs and
then I talked to my boy who lost the
Super Bowl and he's dead and I'm like
dude I ain't even getting shot I think
that's happening with Anthony Davis
versus Kawhi Leonard Kawhi Leonard Taps
out he's absent from those moments that
we're so hyper critical so we're not
hypocritical of him he doesn't even jump
in it's almost like the world is saying
you're better off
not trying then trying and failing and I
see that happening a lot more in terms
of the criticism in terms of the
spotlight on the guy always great to
talk to you appreciate your insights
thank you all right take care D that's
uh Marcellus Wiley former All-Pro
defensive end and host of more to it Dan
Patrick Podcast Network